vous avez ouvert un bar à la baule le
barouf sérieuse toujours pour vous
reconvertir vous êtes vraiment dit à ce
moment là ça ne fait plus je vais
m'arrêter vous vous sentiez mal aimé non
je me suis jamais sentie mal aimé
puisque les gens de la rue
mal aimé par le métier on sait pas si on
est aimé par ce métier je pense que ce
métier même personne en fait ce métier
profite du succès ou pas que vous avez à
un moment voilà il n'ya pas d'amitié là
dedans la famille du cinéma n'existe pas
quand j'ouvre ce bar à la baule je ne
travaille plus du tout c'est à dire j'ai
uniquement parce que vous dites ce que
vous pensez parfois c'est mal interprété
mal
si vous voulez juger par ceux qui
décident et tout d'un coup vous
travaillez plus
donc quand vous travaillez plus il faut
bien remettre le couvert quelque part
avec votre énergie vous avez vous êtes
jeune vous avez des potes vous êtes vous
y croyez on monte un bar à la baule et
ça fait un carton